israel says air raids against syrian and
iranian targets
are retaliation for an iranian-sponsored
operation against an israeli base in the
golan heights
there is also history tonight in the
middle east the u.s secretary of state
has visited the israeli settlements in
the west
bank it's a milestone that brings with
it plenty of criticism
correspondent trey yingst shows us
tonight from tel aviv
secretary of state mike pompeo flies
over the west bank
before landing in an israeli settlement
his visit to a winery marks the first
time
a top u.s diplomat toured the disputed
territory
pompeo's trip is part of a larger
campaign announced this week alongside
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu
to punish organizations deemed
anti-semitic
i know this sounds simple to you mr
prime minister seems
it seems like a statement of fact but i
want you to know that we will
immediately take steps to identify
organizations that engage
in hateful bds conduct and withdraw u.s
government support
for such groups part of the new us
initiative and final gift to israel from
the trump administration
includes labeling products as made in
israel if they originate from
settlements
taco pompeo's visit to an area that is
considered illegally occupied under
international law
triggered protests yesterday with
demonstrators lighting tires on fire
and clashing with the israeli military
this is an
illegal act it's an act of a failed
administration
trying to make himself relevant when
he's one month away from being a nobody
secretary pompeo also visited the golan
heights today
an area taken from syria during the
six-day war the trump administration
formally recognized the golan
as part of israel last year in contrast
to views
held by most of the international
community john trey yanks tonight trey
thanks